As you probably already noticed, the Far From
Home trailer doesn't even slightly acknowledge
the titanic events of Avengers: Infinity War,
in which half the population of the universe
succumbed to sudden death, at least temporarily.
It also seems to sidestep the events of that
movie's forthcoming follow-up, Avengers: Endgame,
which is set to hit theaters only a couple
of months before the release of Far From Home.
To the casual moviegoer, it's as though the
fight against Thanos didn't even happen.
But for dedicated fans of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe, it's pretty weird to see Peter Parker
just suddenly being alive again.
"Peter, you have to tell me what's going on."
Instead of walking around looking shell-shocked
and traumatized, the Far From Home trailer
seems to show the people of the MCU being
back to business as usual.
Happy Hogan is there, Aunt May's there, Nick
Fury's there, and Peter's biggest concern
seems to be his crush on MJ.
Instead of going through an existential crisis
after everything he's seen, Peter is back
to being his plucky self, and has no problem
suiting up to go on an adventure with Nick
Fury.
Both of them seem to have recovered from their
deaths incredibly well.
What's going on?
"Why all the secrecy?
Why not just tell us?"
"Any attempt on the director's life had to
look successful."
"Can't kill you if you're already dead."
The tonal whiplash has led some viewers to
craft theories about why Spider-Man's corner
of the universe is so happy-go-lucky, just
months after everyone on Earth went through
the most tragic events ever.
This doesn't feel like a world that's been
through the apocalypse, so what if it isn't?
What if the world of Far From Home never experienced
Thanos' Decimation, because the Avengers managed
to go back in time and stop it from ever happening?
We all know in our hearts that the heroes
who died from Thanos' snap will be coming
back to life one way or another, if only because
the world demands a sequel to Black Panther.
The default assumption is that the Avengers
will beat Thanos, revive the trillions of
dead people, and then proceed from there.
In that potential sequence of events, everyone
would still have knowledge of the Decimation
happening.
People would be back to life, but the pain
of loss would linger.
So far at least, that does not seem to be
what's happening in Spider-Man: Far From Home.
There’s another theory out there: Far From
Home might secretly be a prequel to Infinity
War, taking place after Homecoming but before
Peter ditched his school bus and saved Iron
Man from getting beaten up.
But according to the filmmakers, this doesn't
seem to be the case.
According to Amy Pascal, one of the producers
of Far From Home, the Spider-Man sequel will,
quote, "start a few minutes after Avengers
4 wraps as a story."
And it's not just her saying that.
Marvel Studios head Kevin Feige has said the
same thing, promising audiences that Far From
Home is indeed set after Infinity War and
Endgame.
According to the MCU producer, Peter will
return to a, quote, "normal life" in Far From
Home.
Of course, it's always possible that the producers
are straight-up lying.
"Alright then, keep your secrets."
"Hnuhmm?"
If it's true that Far From Home takes place
after the events of Endgame, then we're left
with one big question.
How will the story wrap up in a way that fits
with the lighthearted tone of Far From Home?
Reversing the Decimation by bringing people
back to life in Endgame would presumably leave
the people of Earth feeling pretty shaken
up at the start of the Spider-Man sequel.
Even if Thanos' victims didn't remember being
dead, the loved ones they left behind certainly
would.
If that were the case, then forget about going
to Europe, Aunt May probably wouldn't let
Peter leave the house.
"And if you die, I feel like that's on me.
I don't need that on my conscience."
"Not a fan of that Tony Stark."
All this adds up as evidence for the theory
that the Avengers will spend Endgame altering
the timeline to ensure that Thanos never accomplishes
his genocidal goal.
Some believe that the Far From Home trailer
all-but-confirms this theory, which is going
back to basics in a way that seems impossible
in a world after the Snap.
There's already a lot of evidence that Endgame's
plot will heavily involve time travel.
Looking over all the information that we have
at this point, a timeline reset seems more
plausible than ever.
Of course, all of this could change.
Maybe we're being played by the marketing,
and Marvel has a huge surprise in store for
us that no one will see coming..
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
Marvel movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.